For you first encounter with actual WebGL and 3js code, I'll give you a simple
program that creates a scene with one object, a cube. And a few grids
surrounding it. To see it, however, you'll have to get your hands dirty and fix
a few syntax errors. In the code, to the left of the lines that have problems,
you'll see little marks that denote that you need to fix those lines. Make the
corrections, and then try doing the test run, and you should see this. Once you
fix the three syntax errors in the program, you should see something like this
on your screen. Note that you can interact with it. You can move around, zoom
and pan. Try the various mouse controls to see how it works. If you get things
into a broken state, just refresh the page on your browser. Once you've got the
program running, try changing numbers in the code to see the effect. Don't worry
about what the code's doing at this point, I'll be covering that in the lessons
ahead. More importantly, I'll be explaining the underlying physical principles
and mathematics behind this code.